how does one poop when one does not have
a butthole
well for some single-celled organisms
one becomes the butthole such is the
case for amoebas their formlessness
allows them to easily shift their shape
around to take in food via phagocytosis
the amoeba here happens to have found a
nice meal made of a ciliate which is now
contained in a food vacuole filling with
digestive enzymes those enzymes will
eventually break the ciliate down
allowing the amoeba to absorb nutrients
into its cytoplasm
but then what happens with the remains
well as we see with this amoeba here it
gets released amoebas and other similar
organisms use a process called
exocytosis to send waste back to the
membrane where it is removed from their
body